There was so much you might have said here. And, if
you have any ideas that I don't mention, please share them in
the forum. To start, our data's from 2008. So, not only do
we need to account for inflation, but the diamond market is quite
different now than it was. In fact, when I fit models
to this data and predicted the price of the diamonds that I
found off a market, I kept getting predictions that were way too
low. After some additional digging, I found that global diamonds were poor.
It turns out that prices plummeted in 2008 due
to the global financial crisis. And since then prices, at
least for wholesale polished diamonds, have grown at about
6% per year, compound annual rate. The rapidly growing number
of couples in China buying diamond engagement rings might
also explain this increase. You can click on the links
in the instructor notes to learn more about that.
And finally, after looking at the data on price scope,
I realize that diamond prices grew
unevenly across different karat sizes since 2008,
meaning that the model I initially
estimated couldn't simply be adjusted by inflation.